several things the candidates said last
night during the debate were at least
partially untrue
and our paula paula reid is at the white
house fact checking all of it beginning
with perhaps the most important issue of
all
election integrity
president trump made several claims
without evidence to support them
about election integrity in tuesday's
debate including
this one take a look at west virginia
mailman selling the ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers that statement is false
earlier this year a west virginia
mailman pleaded guilty to attempted
election fraud after changing the party
affiliation on five ballot request forms
from democrat to republican but there is
no evidence that this is widespread
and when asked about the devastating
wildfires in california
every year i get the call california's
burning
california is burning if that was
cleaned
if you had forest management good forest
management
you wouldn't be getting those calls the
truth is scientists have said higher
temperatures
stronger winds and drier conditions
caused by climate change
are the real reasons why they have been
worse this year
we should also point out that the
federal government owns and controls
nearly 60 percent of forests in
california
which would make forest management a
federal issue in many cases
meanwhile former vice president biden
made this claim
about manufacturing because what he did
even before covent manufacturing went in
the hole
manufacturing went not whole we found
that to be false
the trump administration actually added
around 443 thousand manufacturing jobs
from january 2017
to this february before the pandemic hit
and on a plan
for how to handle the pandemic between
750 and a thousand people today are
dying
when he was presented with that number
he said it is what it is
the president has no plan he hasn't laid
out anything
that is also not entirely true while
president trump has been criticized for
his coronavirus response
his administration has announced plans
on how to distribute
150 million rapid covid19 tests
and a vaccine once it is available
the trump campaign insists that last
night the president succeeded in his
mission which they believe was to lay
out his america first agenda
and try to trip up his rival some of his
allies say that his aggressive behavior
at times
may have undercut his appeal we see some
of that reflected in our polling this
morning which shows most viewers were
just annoyed by this debate
and found the overall tone to be
negative gail that's
that's what we have here too paula thank
you very much